musicians and sound engineers plumbers
and electricians taxi drivers and
driving instructors hairdressers and
child minders and many others through no
fault of their own risk losing their
livelihoods to you I say this you have
not been forgotten we will not let you
behind we all stand together so to
support those who work for themselves
today I'm announcing a new self-employed
income Support Scheme the government
will pay self-employed people who have
been adversely affected by the
coronavirus a taxable grant worth 80% of
their average monthly profits over the
last three years up to two thousand five
hundred pounds a month this scheme will
be open to people across the UK for at
least three months and I will extend it
for longer if necessary you'll be able
to claim these grants and continue to do
business and we're covering the same
amount of income for a self-employed
person as we are for furloughed
employees who also receive a grant worth
eighty percent to make sure that the
scheme provides targeted support for
those most in need it will be open to
anyone with trading profits of up to
fifty thousand pounds to make sure only
the genuinely self-employed benefit it
will be available to people who make the
majority of their income from
self-employment and to minimize fraud
only those who are already in
self-employment who have a tax return
for 2019 will be able to apply ninety
five percent of people who are majority
self-employed will benefit from this
scheme HMRC are working on this urgently
and expect people to be able to access
the scheme no later than the beginning
of June if you're eligible HMRC will
contact you directly ask you to fill out
a simple online form then pay the grant
straight into your bank account and to
make sure no one who needs
misses out on support we have decided to
allow anyone who missed the filing
deadline in January four weeks from
today to submit their tax return